I can't wait to put this one up The
Adjustment Bureau was originally going
to come out last fall and when they
pushed it back all the way almost to
this spring I was like whew that's not a
good sign but I had confidence because
Matt Damon's a talented actor he's good
at choosing scripts Emily Blunt is also
a very good actress and this film has
really good actors like Anthony Mackie
and Terence Stamp so I had hope and my
hope paid off in The Adjustment Bureau
Matt Damon plays a politician who is
very very very into his career it's
really his whole life until he meets
this girl randomly by chance Emily Blunt
and he keeps bumping into her places by
a chance and eventually he really starts
to get feelings for her then suddenly
without warning he walks into his office
everyone in his office is not moving and
there's all these people in hats in
their room and they're fixing things and
they're moving things but all their that
people are just standing there like
completely frozen and Matt Damon's like
what the H he stumbles upon the
Adjustment Bureau a group of people who
literally control everything that
happens on the earth and these people
don't think Matt Damon's supposed to be
with Emily Blunt so they try to keep
them apart however he's in love
I fully enjoyed this movie I had so much
fun with it Matt Damon is excellent in
this film and Emily Blunt is equally
just as good there have fantastic
chemistry with each other have you seen
the head on screen seem not only
realistic but very very warm not only
were the blossoming feelings between
them and their opening relationship very
real but later in the film their their
emotional depth they took with their
characters was just so well for trained
film was directed very well by george
nolfi there's a lot of really good chase
sequences
in this film it's not a straight action
movie so don't go into it expecting that
it's really like a science fiction
romance the emphasis is really on
character in this film and that's
something that is very important to me
you can have flashy special effects
chase sequences galore shaky-cam blah
blah blah but if you don't care about
those characters you got nothing and
this film makes you care about those
characters it's based on a short story
by philip k dick who brought us things
like Blade Runner and Minority Report
the guy knew science fiction
Matt Damon continues to be one of my
favorite actors she's great at choosing
scripts he makes all of his characters
believable and he's not just the same in
every movie he's always brings a little
different slink to it a political side
of the story was believable as well a
supporting cast did great Anthony Mackie
was fantastic Terence Stamp was very
good whatever they had to do to push the
film back from fall to this spring I'm
glad they did it the main message of the
film is just because someone else thinks
the way you're going in your life may be
wrong doesn't mean that it is if you
know what you want go for it even if it
doesn't seem like it's possible I just
love that message is very inspirational
and at the same time the film was great
summer entertainment I really enjoyed
this movie I really recommend The
Adjustment Bureau I'm going to give a
three and a half out of four stars but
one of my favorite movies of the year so
far definitely soap a does we get si
Rango C The Adjustment Bureau check both
those films out there excellent I think
you